a quiet place was directed by John
Krasinski and stars him and Emily Blunt
and some terrific young actors who play
a family trapped in a world that's been
overrun by monsters they're easily
susceptible to sound with the slightest
noise drawing them in we spent 95 tense
minutes watching this family struggle to
stay completely silent this is a nerve
shredding thriller tense from the
opening scene to the very end
Krasinski proves himself to be a more
than capable director maximizing the
suspense by choosing what he focuses on
when he reveals things to the audience
versus when he reveals them to the
characters really effects the suspense
level the scenes with the creatures are
rarely about the creatures they're about
the characters this isn't just a monster
movie it's a movie about people and
there happens to be monsters lurking
around outside like all of the best ones
it focuses on the characters and it's
about one family struggling to survive
it's sort of like an odd combination of
tremors and 10 Cloverfield Lane the best
of both of those movies it benefits from
a talented cast and one concept taken to
its extremes from the opening scene the
stakes are established and the threat is
very real it's clear that even the
slightest sound could result in death
whereas in some films like the
aforementioned tremors if you create
noises on the ground or they hear you
based off the vibrations of you running
they might come after you you could
still maybe escape and a quiet place if
you make a noise you're probably dead
like instantaneously and so there's this
considerable level of fear throughout
every scene as these characters use sign
language body language and facial
expressions so that we understand the
story and even the subtle character
nuances without needing words and since
there is such limited dialogue to tell a
story like this a filmmaker has to know
how to communicate to the audience
without saying much Krasinski and his
actors excel at this since the
characters are forced to live in this
world they have to change their way of
life which leads to one of my favorite
aspects of this film watching their new
way of living instead of using plates
they might use a lettuce leaf they with
their hands instead of utensils they
will play a board game but they use
pieces of
instead of metal pieces for the most
part they make valid choices often in
horror films we find ourselves angry
with the people on screen baffled by the
idiotic decisions they make but here
everyone seems to have a pretty good
head on their shoulders having
constructed a complex system around
their farm that helps warn each other if
something's wrong that being said this
is a film that could only exist
specifically in this time period it's
set in because from the very beginning
we're told that it's day 89 indicating
that it's 89 days into whatever started
this current predicament with these
monsters on earth and so they already
have a system in place they've already
figured out some things we're not seeing
the mass hysteria of day one we're
seeing how one family has learned to
survive it would be a drastically
different film had it been on day one
having it be later into the event
whatever that event is we now can see a
family that's constructed a system that
works which makes you appreciate these
characters more because they're actually
smart for the most part admit at least
some characters do make some odd choices
there's some confusion and unanswered
questions for one thing it's never
explained how they still have
electricity if it's a generator I don't
remember ever seeing one on top of that
it would make a lot of noise if they
ever had to restart the generator and so
there are nitpicks there are some
unanswered questions similar to the
film's signs this is a film about one
family and we only learn what they learn
we don't know much from the outside the
characters sometimes go up to this big
mill they have and they light a fire and
you can see that in the distance there
are other people who also have fires so
it's not like they're the only people
left but they can't really go into the
world that much due to the fact that
they have to make no sounds otherwise
these things are going to come out of
the bushes and kill them and so the fact
that it takes place later in the
timeline of whenever this event occurred
it gives this specific story some
credibility because we are to assume
that they have discovered some things or
figured some things out you could
nitpick here and there with ideas about
how to kill the monsters that these
characters aren't using but many of
those ideas assume that this family has
endless supplies access to military
weaponry and things like that and if you
start to overanalyze this film I think
you're missing the point
this is a suspense driven thriller with
some really good scares terrific
performances across the board Krasinski
really does a lot of great things on the
screen and this is probably because as a
director he knows exactly what this film
needs whenever a director and actor make
the same project you can really tell
that they understand everything about it
from beginning to end and Krasinski
knows exactly what the film needs for
heightened power and tension Emily Blunt
is amazing as well and they have great
chemistry as they are a couple in real
life and the young kids do a great job
too especially since the daughter they
have is deaf in the film as well as real
life so that's a very authentic
performance that I'm sure she understood
and had a lot to bring to it while I
always didn't necessarily find myself
wrapped up in the family's lives I was
always interested to see what they were
going to do and what decisions they
would make and by the end I did find
myself caring this is a good
old-fashioned thrill ride if you've been
missing that at the movies and better
yet if you need restored faith and
mainstream horror I think a quiet place
can do that for you I'm gonna give it an
A - this is a simple and to the point
thriller that doesn't try to be anything
else than what it is and it knows that
and it's all the better for that so I
ready to play one review I promised that
I would talk to some of you guys about
their reactions that you sent me for a
quiet place your anticipation for it if
you had seen it and I'm gonna share some
of those reactions with you guys as I
promised and hopefully be able to
interact with you more through that app
hello Chris I am super excited because
Emily and John are married in real life
and I'm sure they're gonna use that
chemistry and that love for each other
to make their performances stand out and
be more powerful they did the chemistry
seemed extremely real as I mentioned in
the review it was very strong this feels
like like what it comes at night was
last year kind of creeping up on you and
it looks really good I hope it is
especially with John Krasinski directing
that's exciting
even my girlfriend's excited just
because she likes them well I'm glad
your girlfriend's excited for the film
and I hope you guys have a good time
seeing it there are similarities I guess
in the tension level between it comes
the night and a quiet place but they are
two vastly different films I say it's
like
which meets the last of us just that
tight anxiety of this trailer just gets
me and you know I'm saying to be able to
edge of my seating that theater and what
the fuck is that kid doing with that
loud ass toy I don't know I can't wait
for this movie I think it's gonna be
dope yes the kid the kid does make some
not great choices and that's that's what
I alluded to in the review there are a
couple times where you're like no this
this is day 89 like you know not to turn
on an electronic rocketship right now
that was one of the choices that I think
maybe could have been written better but
it's also a choice that needs to happen
for the rest of the film to make sense I
gotta tell you I'm more nervous than I
am excited about this theater experience
you've put out videos about awful movie
theater experiences this has the
potential to be an all-time stinker
if all it takes is one idiot in the
crowd to start mouthing off during the
actual quiet part of the quiet place
hold it out hope for the most part my
showing was pretty good there was
someone who did bring an infant and
there were specific times where Emily
Blunt or John Krasinski would be like
and in the background I hear that was
about it though it was it was alright it
looks like a very dense experience and
the fact that it's adapted by John
Krasinski is actually very intriguing to
me so yeah I'm very excited for that one
it is indeed sense and Krasinski does a
great job this is his third film
directing some people are reporting that
it's his first it's not true this is his
third directorial effort and I am very
excited to see what he does apparently
comedians turning to directing
mainstream horror Jordan Peele and now
John Krasinski is like the new thing I'm
all for it I don't usually watch that
many horror films in movie theatres
because I hate jump scares but I'm gonna
go for this one it's a film that's very
silent and there are monsters so
obviously there are going to be some
jump scares but they didn't feel cheap
there were a few that were false and I
was kind of like really a raccoon and I
rolled my eyes at that but for the most
part it's actually pretty clever stuff I
mean I loved Emily Blunt and John
Krasinski but I'm always wary of such
movies the premise is good but the
delivery is not always on point so let's
just keep our fingers crossed and see
how the final product comes out and I
just say sir you have an amazing voice
that is one of the most soothing voices
I have heard in a long time like I was
actually listening to that reaction and
I was just kind of like getting really
relaxed yes they are both great in the
film as I've said I hope you enjoy it
when you see it as once quoted from our
beloved HP Lovecraft himself the oldest
and strongest emotion of mankind is fear
and the oldest and strongest kind of
fear is the fear of the unknown okay I'm
just kidding aside from that I am really
looking forward to watching horror films
and I'm usually very picky with horror
films but I love it because it shows
scaring people with silence and tension
that was frightening but I liked it a
lot I watched it like three times thank
you for sending that in thank you to
everybody who sent me reactions it's
really cool to be on Stardust please do
follow me the link is in the description
below I'm gonna try to do more content
that I don't normally get to do here on
YouTube there you know like older films
which I'm trying to give more attention
to things like TV shows episodes you can
do episode reactions there which I never
do just singular episode review so that
will be pretty fun so please do follow
me there and I also want to say thank
you to everyone else who sent reactions
I had a lot to sift through and I
apologize if I couldn't feature yours
you guys are the best please look
forward to more videos thank you so much
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]